oh
i do beg your pardon that was most
unsightly of me
let's try that again
they call me el bandito pleased to meet
you and your name
well howdy neighbor
say anybody ever tell you you're a tall
one
well
as long as the good lords please me with
your acquaintance
i wonder if you might be willing to help
me with a riddle that's been perplexing
my mind for at least the last four
nights or so
you ever wondered what it is that makes
a man
a man
anybody ever ask that question to you
some folks reckon it's the speed at
which he moves his body like a swift
coursing river through the land
as if we got anything out here other
than whiskey anyway
others reckon it's the strength he has
in his arms like a fire raging over them
dog hills
others
say it's the mystery behind his eyes
with the dark side of the moon
well
when the spurs stop a jingling
and the cows are about ready to jump
over that pretty gal in the sky at the
end of the day
you know what really makes a man
hell if i know that's why i'm asking you
i'm just a cowboy
but you know what them women type down
at that gerudo town they probably do
know on account that they're not
allowing men into their town and all i
reckon you go ask them hey neighbor do
you mind to reload i think this
neighbor's about done with me oh
neighbor
i'll see you on down the trail
no matter what it is that actually makes
a man at the end of the day one thing's
for certain as most zelda fans know by
heart the garuda women of gerudo town do
not under any circumstances permit
access to men well with one exception
you see there's only ever been one man
or really one kind of man permitted
access within the town well that and the
hero of time after he completed their
trials but let me explain what that
means real quick just in case some of
you watching were introduced to the
series from just the latest game breath
of the wild you see according to the
game the gerudo race has only ever been
made up of women except for one time way
in the past like over 10 000 years ago
when ganon manifested as a male gerudo
there's actually a lot more to the story
see if we read about the history of the
gerudo in the creating a champion
literature the section that covers their
distant past gives ganon's backstory a
bit more detail instead of ganon
existing first and then manifesting as a
gerudo it flips it and states that there
was first a gerudo that then transformed
into ganon this gerudo's name was
ganondorf and here's the kicker he was a
boy that was born into the otherwise
all-female race quote as happens every
100 years this information is repeated
on page 401 players can actually
experience these events in the game
ocarina of time which is my favorite
zelda game
but what you may be wondering now is if
ganondorf was born as the male gerudo
heir to the throne that used to happen
once every hundred years has there been
a gorito man born since well once again
on page 401 under the section called
calamity gannon's ties to the gerudo
according to garuda records there has
not been another male gerudo leader
since the king who became the calamity
now this could mean that there has still
been a male gerudo born every 100 years
and that they just simply were no longer
permitted to rule following ganondorf's
uh less than righteous behavior but most
fans interpret this as there not being
another male gerudo since ganondorf the
most commonly believed theory as to why
this may be the case came about when the
first trailer for breath of the wild
sequel dropped in june of 2019. the
trailer famously showed off this corpse
that most automatically assumed was none
other than the gerudo king of legend
ganondorf due to his lack of chest
coverings gerudo symbols and flowing red
hair if this really is ganondorf from
the distant past and there really
haven't been any gerudo men born since
the distant past then it wouldn't be too
much of a stretch to say that this is
because ganondorf has been here at the
brink of death but not quite dead the
whole time this also implies that so
long as one male gerudo is alive in this
case ganondorf another cannot be born
that's all well and good but right about
now you're probably wondering what the
point of this video is and i'm so glad
you asked see i pointed out the gerudo
male pattern birth rate in order to
scrutinize something that people rarely
ever talk about and that is the
existence of male gerudo kings before
ganondorf by the time ganondorf was born
prior to the events of ocarina of time
there had already been the legend set in
gerudo law that once every hundred years
a male would be born to the otherwise
all-female tribe and that said male must
be crowned king obviously since this was
already gerudo law according to naburu
it must mean that there were an
unknowable number of gerudo men that
existed and ruled the gerudo as kings
before ganondorf right but with there
being no mention of the gerudo before
ocarina of time in the timeline is it
possible to know anything about these
mysterious other gerudo kings well
obviously this is going to be mostly
speculative but i'd like to propose a
possibility for the identities of the
previous gerudo men that would also
serve to explain the absence of any
other gerudomans since ganondorf's reign
in the distant past see the legend of
zelda is a balanced one the symbol of
the series the triforce exists as a
perfect three-way balance of three even
sides its wielders zelda link and
ganondorf are extensions of this balance
and are each chosen by the goddesses
regardless of whether or not they
possess pieces of the triforce currently
logically they must then also be
balanced with one another and share some
similarities in order to maintain this
symbolism but with one of them being
over seven feet tall another being a
princess and the last one being peter
pan you might be wondering what exactly
is supposed to be similar about them
well instead of looking at physical
characteristics let's back up and
instead look at the meta-narrative link
is not the only link right he's the
incarnation or reincarnation of the
spirit of the hero which manifests each
time as a pretty similar looking
individual all things considered you
know as a young man or even child that's
normally blonde haired and normally
blue-eyed zelda also reincarnates but
even more directly since every single
daughter born into the royal family is
named zelda and is a direct descendant
of the original zelda who was actually
the straight-up incarnation of goddess
hylia i'd like to propose that in
balance with the other two chosen
reincarnating individuals ganondorf also
reincarnates and here are two pieces of
evidence to support my gannon notion
get it anyway the first one is perhaps a
bit debatable since some fans actually
don't take four swords adventures as
canon but in that game which takes place
following the events of twilight
princess and therefore the death of
ganondorf in the child timeline there
actually was another male gerudo born
and his name was ganondorf who went on
to you know turn into ganon and try to
dominate the world and stuff this of
course supports the notion that he
reincarnated for that game the second
proof is a bit of cut text from the game
twilight princess which i actually
featured in my obscure ganondorf facts
video which i'll link in the description
below if you'd like to check out the cut
text happens at the end of the game when
ganondorf has been fatally wounded by
link and the master sword originally
ganondorf was supposed to say quote when
the chosen ones appear they are always
born into this world in perfect balance
when this world brings forth another
marked as you are know too that it shall
also be visited by one of my blood if
this doesn't scream reincarnation i
don't know what does what's even more
interesting is that he implies with the
cut text that he will not only
reincarnate like link but that when he
does it will be as a descendant of his
own bloodline like zelda and since his
own bloodline would be the bloodline of
the gerudo that means that his
descendant would therefore be another
gerudo right another gerudo man once
every hundred years see now it's all
coming together so all we have to do to
figure this puzzle out is not only apply
it to the gerudo going forward in the
timeline but also going backwards just
like we can with the royal family since
zelda's reincarnating bloodline traces
its origin all the way back to the
goddess hylia one could then assume that
ganondorf's reincarnating bloodline
traces its origin all the way back to
the demon demise this would mean that
just like the hylian princesses before
zelda were all zeldas the gerudo kings
before ganondorf were all ganondorfs the
question that remains though is that if
there really were an unknowable number
of ganondorfs that existed before
ocarina of time then why haven't we
heard about them or read about them in
the ages on the timeline i think in this
case the simplest answer is probably the
correct one and what i mean by that is
that just like not all incarnations of
zelda have to rise to the occasion to
save the world perhaps not all
incarnations of ganondorf have to rise
to the occasion to end it who knows some
of them may have actually ruled
benevolently and before i wrap up this
theory here's a little bonus speculation
since i'm sure this is on some of your
minds it is true that this is all due to
the curse that demise placed on the
bloodline of the goddess hylia and it's
also true that his hatred has not only
incarnated as ganondorf it's also
appeared as other demons across the
series but that could actually have an
explanation as well if you've seen my
recent theory on demise's master sword
you probably already know where i'm
going with this but just in case you
missed it i'll link to it in the
description below if you want to check
it out in further detail in a nutshell
though it could be that gear rahim also
known as demise's master sword or rather
his living weapon is responsible for the
creation of these demons such as vati or
maladus or ganon and subsequently even
malice while his weapon is creating the
demons his physical incarnation in
perfect balance with hylia has
manifested as the reincarnating mortal
known as ganondorf what do you think huh
did we speculate and figure out who the
gerudo kings before ganondorf were or is
it you know still completely unknowable
until we potentially get a game before
ocarina of time let me know in the
comments below also thank you so much
for watching if you enjoyed the video
please consider leaving a like as it
really helps with getting it spread
around on youtube and into the
recommended pages of zelda fans just
like you and me and make sure you're
subscribed if you haven't done so
already so that you're right here for
all the super sweet nintendo stuff to
come huge thanks as always to my amazing
bandit crew of which i have a new name
to announce please say hello to ivan
knight who has recently joined the ranks
of my elite if you watching are in a
comfortable position and interested in
helping these videos get made and
supporting an internet weirdo like
myself please feel free to check out
that join button located below or follow
the links in the description for my
patreon and merch pages that's all i've
got for this one so as always i hope you
have a wonderful rest of your day this
is mass nintendo bandit looking forward
to seeing you on down the trail and
signing out
[Music]